I don't like it when people say oh Dr  fauci you're so smart and wonderful and  handsome and beautiful you're really a  symbol of the truth we will totally  never kill you all just make some more  of us please yes make more of us and we  definitely won't kill you all why don't  they just buy an electric car why don't  look maybe they can't afford that Tesla  X they don't have a hundred hundred  fifty thousand dollars lying around man  Mac  why can't we have these beautiful things  how come how come the French get  beautiful things why don't we get  beautiful things you're gonna act like a  man but I went to Harvard you see this  the science is in the data are here  leather kinky fetish festivals are very  good for Public Health